this man is the uh must listen must
see must read on everything ufc he has
built his brand to say the least
he is ariel helwani here on the rich
eisen show after ufc 263 how are you sir
rich
it's great to be back on great to hear
from you and fitting
that we speak on this day of all days my
final day at espn who better than rich
eisen
to let me know that everything is going
to be okay as i venture into the great
unknown yeah
wow okay well that is pretty
cool did i just break some news no no no
i heard that you were
follow me on social media rich is this a
one-way relationship
it is not i do follow you i knew that
you were you were
parting ways i didn't know today was the
day and this was the
first post uh worldwide leader in sports
interview
that i did not know well technically i'm
still under contract so i'm not looking
to
burn any bridges on the way out but this
could
well be the final thing that i do
as an espn employee at least front
facing
so bittersweet mixed feelings
uh i actually just finished my my last
show with my partner daniel cormier so
i'm a little emotional right now perhaps
that's why i'm dumping this on your lap
no it's okay
it does feel fitting uh considering your
history there
and all that you've accomplished
afterwards well i'm i'm
i'm um happy to talk about it with you
i mean look uh some of my greatest days
of my life
um and not just professionally was at
espn
and oh great you know we've made a huge
mistake no no
uh no and i met my wife in the newsroom
there
my children are technically espn babies
because of all that
um and you know i'll i'll i will shoot
you straight the espn platform
is immense absolutely immense i still
get people
humming the sports center theme to me in
the airport and i'm like you know you
know i'm not there anymore for
it's been 18 years and they they don't
know like they just
so that's the good part is they'll just
assume wherever you are it's still
espn anyway i'm just going to say none
of this is making me feel better by the
way no no no but
but but i i i've had 18 other immensely
successfully enjoyable years you know
and um uh so
you know the grass is green man it's
just as green as it
it was with you being where you are were
ariel
you know literally and figuratively
right if you go
no i feel like you really uh you really
honed in on the word green
but the the truth is as i'm trying to
make light of all this
uh working for espn at espn was a dream
come true because of people like you the
fact that i can call you
a friend and that we have a relationship
is still
surreal to me um and i would be lying if
i said
i expected to last just three years i
was hoping for
a run quite you know maybe not quite
like yours but at least
uh similar in length um but it's a crazy
business
and you know i i it was my decision to
leave and i'm excited about the future
but i agree with everything like it's
you know obviously a lot more people
know who i am the platform the spotlight
the
profile is all much bigger but uh i feel
at peace with it all and uh i'm i'm very
excited about
what's to come okay and just uh as much
as you want to share do you know what's
to come do you have an income can i
break the news right here now
sure if you got it for me andrew
marchand online one please
uh the guy's incessant he just won't
stop bothering me
uh the truth is i don't i don't have
anything signed
so i don't feel comfortable just yet um
i'm working with a great publicist named
zack rosenfield set it all up
and uh it's gonna be great that's great
man good hand
yeah you are in great hands he's uh the
publicist of this show and me personally
and also nate diaz uh
yes i love that you know diaz rich
eisens and our clients for the same
person
i text i texted him after ufc 263 i
actually posted this i got his
permission to post it
i'm like i don't know who else you
represent but you know if i'm on one end
of the spectrum of
who you represent nate diaz has to be on
the other end of it
um so i guess let's let's get into that
um you know
have have you ever seen a a fighter or
any athlete
who loses and um gets the hearts and
minds of the fan base to the point where
it feels like you won
and nate so happy that that you take
that angle because that is
nathan diaz and his brother nick who for
the longest time was way more popular
than
than nathan but now uh you know nathan
has become a bigger star because of his
activity beating conor etc
that's them in a nutshell like if you
were just some casual sports fan and you
went up
to wikipedia or something and you looked
up diaz's record you're like what 13
losses for this guy like this guy is a
pedestrian journeyman fighter but that's
not
understanding the magic of who he is and
why people love him so much
the magic of who he is and why people
love him so much is because of those 60
seconds because he can
lose a fight for 24 straight minutes
nothing was in doubt he was on route to
losing and then turn it on
in the final 60 seconds and then as you
said walk out
feeling like the winner controlling the
narrative having people even more
excited about him having them forgetting
forgetting about the 24 previous minutes
it's really
an incredible thing that only he can
pull off because he has an incredible
charm
he's a very smart guy he doesn't get
enough credit for how smart he is
and in mma thankfully wins and losses
don't mean as much
as they do in boxing where they're
fixated on
45-0 24-1 all this stuff and mma the
fans love you if you're real if you're
authentic if you
fight your heart out if you bring it if
you're entertaining
and some of the best fighters in the
history of the sport have double digit
losses like like diaz but
no one quite has a cult-like following
like him
everyone loves them and uh credit to him
you know
i wrote this on saturday leon edwards
won the fight but nathan diaz won the
night
and once again he proves that he doesn't
need a w next to his name in order to
gain new fans he did it on saturday for
the way in which he ended that fight
especially when you know he performs at
his best when
when bleeding profusely and then he
takes the pineapple express to the uh
to the post-game press conference the
post-match
podium you know and then uh so what
what's
like next for him what's his future what
do you think
foreign spot because again like he
picked leon edwards leon edwards was the
guy on the nine fight unbeaten streak
diaz was the guy who's coming off a loss
who wasn't ranked and said oh i want to
fight him and edwards who some would
argue
should just wait for a title i was like
oh no no i'll fight this guy who's on
ranked that's just
how big of a star nathan diaz is you
know back in 2014
if i may diaz was in talks to fight
someone and he was giving ufc president
dana white
some headaches as he's been known to do
and i was at a a media scrum
dana was there holding court and he went
on this tension about how
diaz doesn't have any right to ask for x
y and z
and famously said nathan diaz is not a
needle mover
this is a quote that you can look up
it's on youtube people wrote about it
and it's just so amazing to me that he
is one of the very few needle movers
in the sport like this man moves the
needle the biggest stars
in sport and entertainment go out of
their way to watch this man fight
and so the world is a zoyster i think we
wait and see what happens july 10th
against dustin poirier conor mcgregor
fight and then if conor loses that fight
and guess what even if he wins that
fight it might be the time to finally do
that trilogy you don't want to wait too
long
diaz is hot conor will be hot again i
would like to see it
before it's all said and done i think
the fans would as well ariel helwani
here on the rich eisen show what are the
other headlines that stick to you
uh out of 263 well uh there's a young
man named brandon moreno
who's the first mexican-born ufc
champion ever he won the title
on saturday defeating davis and
figueretto the flyweight title
and this is a really big deal for the
company as you know mex
ministry they love their fighting over
there but the ufc hasn't quite broken
through with
its own star over the years they've
tried really hard they've done reality
shows open gyms held events all this
stuff and more but they never quite
broke through
they had a mexican-american champion a
heavyweight champion several years ago
named cain velasquez but not the same
moreno is from tijuana
his family has uh a a pinata
making business like they are mexican
through and through
and he is as entertaining as it gets has
an incredible personality he was cut
from the ufc
three years ago works his way back up
and now he's the first mexican-born
champion in the history of the promotion
he's going to open a lot of doors for
them he's going to be a huge star if
they promote him correctly and then of
course the other big one
is radasanya returning to his natural
weight class 185 pounds
defeating his rival marvatory great
performance i thought out of him
and he of course is still one of the big
faces one of the stars of the ufc
well we've we we've had him on this show
twice uh
and i i mean i am so
uh much a fan of his just his wattage
his personality his
in his um uh
enthusiasm i mean it's there there's
really not many people
like israel what what is his next step
in reality in his future
as you know he's been on this show and
and i i
i will just say um this was not my
language
um he still wants to take jon jones and
scratch his manhood across his face
uh in the home of the las vegas raiders
like that's literally what his plan is
is is that a possibility um there should
be a possibility it could be a
possibility but they're now
sort of on different paths different
wavelengths you know john is trying to
do this thing where he's moving up the
heavyweight
izzy is now at 185 so there's now one
full weight class in between them which
is the 205 pound division the light
heavyweight division they could
obviously meet in the middle
but it seems like john who's having his
own contract issues with the ufc again
right now
is really focused on this heavyweight
title and so there is a chance like i
think a lot of people and even izzy
for the longest time was predicting that
they would meet in july at rage
raider stadium that's obviously not
going to happen um
there were people who thought at some
point in 2021 they would fight
and now it's looking like they're going
in complete different directions so it
would be unfortunate because they have a
lot of heat
they're they're very much not on the
same page they don't like each other
but honestly at this juncture i wouldn't
be surprised if they don't if only
because
you know john's going up from 205 to
heavyweight
izzy's now comfortable at 185 he moved
up to 205 recently lost that fight
crazier things have happened but right
now i don't suspect it's next for either
men
all right uh so what is the uh what's
the next
big fight for you and a big
uh story for you ariel hawani hewani
other than trying to find employment um
it would be july 10th uh las vegas the
return of conor mcgregor nothing bigger
than
conor nothing bigger than that the
trilogy fight against dustin poirier
and of course you know dustin beat him
in july
in the rematch so there's a lot at stake
here for conor the winner of this fight
is going to fight for the lightweight
title
and conor is still such a big draw but
he needs to get that w he needs to get
back on track you
your your drawing power will only stick
around you know in mma
they're a lot more lenient like i said
in boxing so only stick around for so
long
he needs to get this win over pourier
guy who he beat you know around seven or
so years ago
but top of mind right now from being
honest
with you uh today rich it is game one
of the eastern conference as i like to
say semi-finally even though i don't
even understand what they're doing
stanley cup said whatever
my montreal canadiens yes
going to vegas of all places that the
crepit town
is looking to get game one tonight led
by the great kerry price i know you're a
big hockey show i'm sure you spent three
hours talking about it already but i had
to get a plug in for my canadian you
should ariel it's been a while since uh
you know they uh they won um it's sort
of like
93. i know like if somebody's bored like
kyler murray said uh over the weekend
that he never rooted for the cowboys
because they were always to use his
phrase ass
and um he was born in 97 so when were
you born
ariel i was born in 1982 um
okay i had success in the 80s don't
remember it
very well i do remember 93 they beat the
kings in five games
the parade i remember all of that and no
canadian team has won a cup since then
well that's because they checked that's
because they checked mcsorley's stick
ariel you know that right and what a
move it was
it was so savvy were you you weren't at
espn at the time right no i got to espn
in 1996
so ah okay yeah uh but that's a great
call from you yeah the great jacques de
maris pulled that one out of his
back pocket oh yeah oh i was when i was
at michigan jacques de mares was the uh
the head coach of the the red wings
oh yes yes so i remember i remember
jacques uh
in those times okay well that's pretty
cool you got that and then the knicks uh
the knicks made the playoffs are you
ready to say sorry
sorry for what what am i saying sorry
come on i mean first of all
you were mr negative nancy the entire
season
and you know you you could i get what
you're saying
i get your feelings what am i saying
what am i saying ariel say the words say
say the words what am i saying don't
like james dolan right don't like the
way the team has been run for the last
20 years but as a new yorker in your
heart yes
you're mr hollywood now how could you
not be happy after the year the new york
had
with everyone proclaiming that new york
city was dead right in the midst of the
pandemic
to see those people cheering amazing
them led by tom thibodeau new york's own
essential i know he's from connecticut
but we'll claim him as a new yorker and
to see this
group of ragtag players who no one
wanted led by julius randle who's
certainly no one wanted do those things
come on there was a part of you that was
a little bit absolutely seeing the
garden filled and
and full throat and you know and even
chanting about how
jose altuve sucks like that's that's
old-school new yorker stuff like rooting
chanting against the houston astro you
know what i mean like they were they
were they were ready to roll
and i i just heard the the the the the
arena
uh in full throat and it was amazing and
then i just remembered
how much with a white hot fury i hate
the owner and how
he treats fans and how he views them as
basically pawns in his game
just like charles oakley and i still
can't get through it i can't
i just can't and i and i i i could still
be
a a new yorker through and through and
not have to root for the knicks
i i just won't use them as my identity
as a new yorker
in the same way wait for it ariel you
ready here i'm going to come over the
top
in the same way that your identity is
not tied to espn in terms of who it is
seriously you are who you are you do
your job
the way you do your job you have a fan
base because people
are attracted to your style and who you
are and you are
you are your own fingerprint you are
your own
personality and your own brand espn gave
you an
immense platform and you utilized it and
the fact that you are not with them
anymore doesn't mean that they don't
like you or think you're not as good as
you used to be
or anything like that it's business now
go move on and go find your next
your next thing and and you still who
you are that's why i'm still the new
yorker i don't need james dolan's team
and laundry to tell me i'm a new yorker
how does that sound
well i was going to come back with some
like sassy reply go for it
i love it that's the new yorker in us
and and we don't root for the owner we
root for the jersey and the team and
what they represented the memories and
the joy
we only have one life to live and so if
this brings us to but then you come back
with that
you know that that that piece of advice
and and
and you know i have so much respect for
you i can't say anything you can't
no i know i know i went personal there
but it is still personal to me that he
put oakley
in uh overnight i just can't i can't
that broke it man that broke that broke
my bond
that broke my bond that that what you've
done before then
um i was close but i was still rooting
for the team you know and but it was
still great to see them
and i everything that they do um and
what they stand for in terms of a new
yorker's scrappiness
right i i i totally buy into that
i get it i get it but you know if i if i
i lived in new york and i wanted to see
great basketball i would
take the trip to brooklyn man i really
would don't say it i would
it's a fact come on don't say that
you don't mean that
[Laughter]
i absolutely do if i lived in new york i
would do that
i would do that you hear that organ you
hear the defense
you think back to the next and by the
way i know i saw a lot of people
speaking of the nets like the day that
kyrie and kd you know announced that
they were going to brooklyn a lot of
people said this is the darkest day in
the history of the next not even close
to the darkest day the darkest day was
that night in february back in i believe
2017 when they dragged oakley out of
madison square garden and that was the
darkest day oakley
and his number 34 should be in the
rafters starks and his number three
should be in the rafter
mason and his fourth like what those
teams meant that these knicks teams to
all of us
right it's crazy that they don't honor
them more so i couldn't agree with you
more but now as as a parent and as
a father of two boys who are growing up
loving sports like i want them to have
that feeling and maybe you could say oh
you're you're doing them a disservice
you can't go
make them lakers fans or something like
that but no that's my team orange and
blue patrick ewing 33
van gundy and dolan can never take that
away from me he could do whatever he
wants to the fans
but for my couch at home i will root for
the knicks because he doesn't represent
the knicks in my opinion ariel helwani
everybody
all right ariel well whatever your your
next stop uh let me know
uh i will have you on anytime you want
to promote anything that you are doing
i just hope you know you you go to a
place that uh allows you to do what you
want and
makes you feel the way you deserve to
feel and
um and and allows you to come on because
the number of people that that
eventually go i just joined this place
they won't let me come on your show i've
lost track so hopefully you know you
that ain't happening uh in fact i mean
i'll just say
i hope i'm not breaking the fourth wall
that was said to me not about your show
but about
other shows when i got to the worldwide
leader and that's not how i roll because
people like you
and many other people dan for example
patrick and levitard
you guys had my back and you put me on
the air before i was an espn guy
so what kind of person would i be if i
say no i can't now that i'm with
so-and-so so to me it's about
relationships and uh
having that independence and so whenever
you want me i will be there i appreciate
it i don't know i mean you look the
other way with dolan so
i mean
congrats on your uh new endeavor
wherever that may be ariel let's chat
soon
thank you guys take care have a great
day all right all right there you go
aaron
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here